i'm locked in already right now no dates
for me
machine gun kelly is letting fans know
that megan fox has him cuffed
and he plans to be locked in for ever
the rapper whose real name is colson
baker appeared on buzzfeed celebs
thirst tweets where he read thirsty
tweets fans wrote about him
machine gun kelly i just want to let you
know that i'm free this sunday to go on
a date just let me know if you're free
sunday because i'm free and would like
to take you on a date
machine gun kelly politely declined the
offer and made it clear that he's
off the market hopefully for good
i'm locked in already right now no dates
for me probably ever
the bloody valentine rapper and megan
have been going strong
since they first were linked in may with
the actress appearing in his music video
and recently the two have been giving
fans a glimpse inside their relationship
on social media
[Music]
early august megan took to instagram to
share this photo
of her and her boo cuddled up following
a swim
captioning it quote achingly beautiful
boy
my heart is yours machine gun kelly
posted a similar shot of the two
captioning it quote waited for eternity
to find you again
the couple first met in march on the
puerto rico set
of midnight in the switchgrass but due
to the coronavirus crisis
filming was suspended shortly after in
may
megan and her husband brian austin
greene who she has three kids with
announced that they called it quits
after 10 years of marriage
since then things have been heating up
between megan and machine gun kelly
was in a room with him and said hello to
him and looked into his eyes
i knew just last month the two went
very public with their romance on the
podcast give them la la
with randall which is co-hosted by la la
kent
and randall emmett the director of
midnight and the switchgrass
they chatted about their instant
connection and megan explain
how she chunks her bond with mgk up to
destiny
i knew right away that he was what i
call a twin flame
which is what does that mean so instead
of a soul mate a twin flame is actually
where a soul has like ascended to a high
enough level that it can be split into
two different bodies
at the same time so we're actually two
halves of the same soul
i think wow and i said that to him
almost immediately
what because i i felt it right away this
is definitely a new chapter in megan's
life
and last year she opened up to e.t about
living without any regrets
for me to sit and be resentful or to
really regret
something to suffer because of something
that i did in my past
i think is pointless because any choice
that i made
i have to accept responsibility for it
and i also have to acknowledge how
it grew me as a person because there was
not one thing that i went through that
was trying or difficult
that didn't help me to grow into a
better individual a smarter
stronger more patient more kind person
so there's no point in regretting those
things and i also don't believe that
i've ever been
a victim again i think that i manifested
my reality
and it was a reflection of my own belief
systems and so i had to live through it
and work through it
and continue to grow and change my
beliefs so that my reality would change